THESE ARE CALLED
MUSICAL >> Kimberly: WE HAVE
HEARD ENOUGH EXCUSES FROM
HILLARY CLINTON AS TO WHY SHE DD
HILLARY CLINTON AS TO WHY SHE D'
HILLARY CLINTON AS TO WHY SHE DT
WON THE WHITE HOUSE.
I DIDN'T THINK THERE WERE ANY
MORE LEFT.
BEHOLD.
THERE IS ANOTHER.
HERE IS THE LATEST.
>> YOU MAY BE THE ONLY
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE SINCE
WORLD WAR II WOULD STAND UP AND
SAY I'M A CAPITAL S, AND YOU
DID.
DID IT HURT YOU?
>> PROBABLY.
IT'S HARD TO KNOW.
BUT IF YOU ARE IN THE IOWA
CAUCUSES AND 41% OF DEMOCRATS
ARE SOCIALISTS OR SELF-DESCRIBED
SOCIALISTS AND I AM ASKED, ARE
YOU A CAPITALIST, AND I SAY YES
BUT WITH APPROPRIATE REGULATION
AND WITH APPROPRIATE
ACCOUNTABILITY, THAT PROBABLY
GETS LOST.
OH, MY GOSH SHE'S A CAPITALIST.
YES, ANOTHER, ADDING THEM UP.
WHAT'S GOING ON HERE, GREG?
I KNOW YOU GET DELIGHTED EVERY
TIME HILLARY MAKES AN
APPEARANCE.
>> Greg: THIS IS ESPECIALLY
HILARIOUS BECAUSE SHE'S RIGHT.
A LARGE PORTION OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY ARE SNIVELING
SOCIALISTS.
THEY ARE FOR UNIVERSAL BASED
INCOME, HIGHER TAXES, GUARANTEED
JOBS.
IDENTITY OVER THE INDIVIDUAL.
THEY WEREN'T VOTING FOR TRUMP.
SHE WAS THEIR ONLY CHOICE.
PARTY WOULD DISAGREE WITH HER.
THEY ARE CHASING A FAILED
SYSTEM.
WE HAVE THE MOST EFFECTIVE
POLITICAL ECONOMICAL SYSTEM IN
THE HISTORY OF THE WORLD THAT
THE DEMOCRATS ARE LIKE SIDESHOW
BOB.
THEY KEEP WALKING INTO RAKES.
>> Kimberly: THAT WAS A GOOD
SYNOPSIS.
THE ANALOGY WAS GOOD.
I THINK WE SHOULD MOVE THIS
EXCUSE TO NUMBER ONE.
IT HAS SOME CREDENCE.
WELL DONE.
>> Greg: BUT IT IS A LIE TOO.
>> Dana: INSTRUCTIVE ABOUT
WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN IN 2020
BECAUSE THE GROUND SHIFTED UNDER
HILLARY CLINTON'S FEET FROM WHEN
SHE RAN INTO THOUSAND EIGHT TO
2016.
IN 2008, BERNIE SANDERS COULD
NOT HAVE RUN AS AN AVOWED
SOCIALIST AND WON.
YOU THINK ABOUT THE POLITICS OF
JFK, BILL CLINTON, EVEN
PRESIDENT OBAMA.
EVERYTHING HAD CHANGED.
I DON'T WHAT THEY ARE GOING TO
DO IN 2020 BECAUSE IF THE
ECONOMY IS GOING -- IT'S GOING
SUPER WELL NOW, CONTINUING TO
2020 PROBABLY FOR LITTLE WHILE,
HOW ARE THEY GOING TO MAKE AN
ARGUMENT THERE SHOULD BE
SOMETHING DIFFERENT?
THAT WILL BE VERY DIFFICULT.
IF YOU LOOK AT A PLACE LIKE OHIO
RIGHT NOW, IT'S A HEATED
GUBERNATORIAL RACE.
THE BERNIE SANDE              BR
THE BERNIE SANDE              BI
THE BERNIE SANDE              B
THE BERNIE SANDE              BA
THE BERNIE SANDE              BD
THE BERNIE SANDE              BR
THE BERNIE SANDE              BS
THE BERNIE SANDE              BP
THE BERNIE SANDE              BO
THE BERNIE SANDE              BT
THE BERNIE SANDE              BR
THE BERNIE SANDE              B,
YOU HAVE A STATE TURNING RED IN
ITS MORE A REPUBLICAN WILL WIN.
>> Kimberly: SERIOUSLY
SCRIBBLING AT HOME TO COME UP
WITH ANOTHER IDEA.
THIS TACTIC IS NOT GOING TO
WORK.
YOU SAW THE GROUNDSWELL OF
SUPPORT FOR BERNIE SANDERS,
PROGRESSIVE, FORCING THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY TO TACK FURTHER
TO THE LEFT.
>> Jesse: DEMOCRATS LIKE
BERNET BECAUSE HE FIGHTS FOR THE
POOR AND HE LOOKED POOR.
THAT REALLY HELPED HIM.
THE HAIR AND EVERYTHING.
DEMOCRATS DON'T DO WELL WHEN
THEY RUN REALLY WELL.
GORE, JOHN KERRY, HILLARY.
YOU NEED SOMEONE WHO IS A LITTLE
BIT DISHEVELED AND CAN FIGHT FOR
THE LITTLE GUY.
CAPITALISM IS A DIRTY WORD FOR
DEMOCRATS.
THEY LOVE SOCIALISM BUT THEY
CAN'T DEFINE IT.
YOU ASK A DEMOCRAT, WHERE HAS
SOCIALISM WORKED?
THEY THEY CAN'T SAY.
THEY WILL POINT TO SWEDEN.
SWEDEN IS FINE IF YOU WANT TO BE
TAKEN CARE OF FOR THE REST OF
YOUR LIFE, IF YOU WANT TO LIVE A
MIDDLE-CLASS LIFE.
IF YOU START WITH NOTHING IN
THIS COUNTRY, YOU CAN HAVE A
YACHT.
IN SWEDEN, THAT WILL NEVER
HAPPEN.
IN AMERICA, THERE IS UPWARD
MOBILITY AND GRIT AND IT'S
REWARDED.
THE DEMOCRATS GET THEMSELVES IN
TROUBLE BECAUSE THEY ARE ALWAYS
OFFERING HANDOUTS INSTEAD OF
HAND OPS.
>> Kimberly: THAT WAS LIKE AN
INFOMERCIAL.
>> Greg: THERE ARE SOME VERY
GOOD-LOOKING POOR PEOPLE.
I WAS POOR FOR A LONG TIME.
>> Jesse: I AM STILL MORE
POORER THAN YOU.
AND BETTER LOOKING.
>> Greg: [LAUGHS]
YOU JUST PROVED YOUR POINT.
>> Kimberly: JUST A REALLY
DOESN'T MEAN THAT.
THERE IS A MOM TEXT COMING.
>> Jesse: SHE ALREADY HIT ME
UP FOR A POLL.
>> Juan: YOU ARE RECITING
RASMUSSEN WHICH IS CONSERVATIVE
LEANING.
THEY HAVE ALMOST HALF OF
GUARANTEED JOBS IN THE COUNTRY.
I GUESS THEY ARE SOCIALISTS.
WHAT YOU HAVE IN THIS MOMENT IN
TERMS OF INCOME INEQUALITY IS A
HEIGHTENED SENSE OF CONCERN.
PEOPLE FEELING "I GOT LEFT
BEHIND.
I AM NEVER GOING TO CATCH UP.
I CAN'T GET A HOUSE AS GOOD AS
MY PARENTS."
I REMEMBER YOU GUYS GOING AFTER
HER LIKE CLINTON DURING THE
CAMPAIGN, WHY DOESN'T SHE
RELEASE HER SPEECHES TO
WALL STREET.
OH, SO THIS PART OF THE SAME
ATTACK INITIATED BY
BERNIE SANDERS.
WHO CAME WITHIN ONE PERCENTAGE
POINT OF TYING HILLARY CLINTON
IN IOWA, A STATE WHERE ABOUT THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE THERE, THEY ARE
SELF-DESCRIBED AS SOCIALISTS.
THOSE NUMBERS ARE NATIONAL.
IF YOU LOOK AT YOUNG DEMOCRATS.
I THINK THEY ARE CONFUSING
SOCIALISM WITH POPULISM OF THE
TRUMP, BERNIE SANDERS STYLE
WHICH IS REALLY ABOUT SPEAKING
TO AN ECONOMIC NEED IN A NATION
WHERE THE OPPORTUNITY FOR